hey guys my name is Ryan Vaughn and this
is Graham Nardone and we're producers on
the sims 4 team we heard that you guys
wanted to see some live gameplay so
today we have a special treat we're
gonna take you through the demo we gave
to press and journalists at e3 last
month now Before we jump into the game I
would like to say that this is beta
software actually from a month ago so if
you guys see any bugs or any kind of
hiccups through router or game play
today just know that this is an
unfinished version of the game yeah a
lot of work went into preparing it for
e3 and it's great saying how the games
progressed since then
yeah but you know what I don't want to
tease people too much let's get this
thing going straight okay and we're
gonna fly through your cast I know
people want to see gameplay so I just
want you to check out this handsome sim
here look at this guy I got to show off
a little bit I got the audience game but
what I really want to do for Meissen
here is start setting them up with a
little bit of his personality and how
I'm gonna do that first is to give him
an aspiration for myself I'm gonna go
with the knowledge aspiration and within
there I'll take the computer whiz track
now he's warning yeah and right along
with it came this trait that was paired
the quick learner trait and that's
really gonna help me kind of complete
that aspiration and reach my goals in
life and in addition to this pair tray
you also have the ability to pick from a
variety of different personality traits
as well sure so I have three more I can
select from here and I'll go with the
eat first that works for me and let's
see what else I want here oh I hate to
say it but I really am a bit of a snob
actually online man it's true and now
one more biggest social tree oh oh gotta
go with the road love it well as you
guys can see as grant picks out these
traits it's changing the behavior of a
sim but more importantly it's gonna
change the way we play the game when we
jump
right now hey really quickly Ryan what
what would things look like check out
this guy okay a good excuse
another great looking sim now I noticed
something was just a little bit off with
them so really quick tweak here here we
go there oh yeah that's your gonna go
that's better than full demo on me you
know in a broadcast right we're making
realistic sincere I gotta make somebody
looks believed right you never know come
on and I see you got one more trait mess
in there we're gonna have some fun on
this broadcast today I'm gonna make you
a bro we're gonna hang out have a good
time
well there's nothing that a bro loves
more than hanging out with another bro
so we're gonna jump straight into limo
now and see how our sins traits and how
their emotions change the way we're
gonna play the game now we're gonna load
into our all-new world called Willow
Creek and into one of the specific
neighborhoods within that world called
magnolia blossom Park we're really
excited to show it you guys and here we
are looking pretty good you see some of
those angry dudes right there yeah
looking pretty angry right now so Ryan
is actually in the very angry motion
State and this happens to be because he
got in a bit of an altercation with
another sim earlier and he's got the
steaming mad mullah now you guys know
mullets from The Sims 3 and mullets are
what drive your Sims emotions in The
Sims 4 so different mood let's of
different intensities and types will
push your Sims into different emotions
now the best thing about emotions is
that you the player have complete
control over them and you can also use
them to your benefit now Ryan's very
angry I put him into this emotion by
giving him into that fight and now I
want to take advantage of the benefits
of this emotion so Graham click on the
ground right there and you're gonna see
that Ryan actually has a set of specific
unique interactions that are tied
directly to the way sim Ryan is feeling
you can see what the color indicators
there Ryan can do peeve push-ups or
sit-ups of fury because he's feeling
that angry L it looks like a friend has
come round chat with him in a second I'm
gonna get you out
push-ups here was great no they can shop
for work now this is actually good
enough what I want to point out because
sim Ryan is feeling that angry he can
actually leverage all of that anger
channel all his distress and pure rage
into his workout and build his athletic
skill faster than he would if he was
feeling fine so this is just the first
example of how you the player can take
advantage of the way your sims are
feeling and really gain all the benefits
from it
check out for some good crunches right
there you know all right now let's take
a look at sim Graham here now
Graham is feeling me much different than
Ryan he's actually feeling energized and
this is a result of a brisk shower mulet
because he took a shower this morning as
well as that personality trait we gave
him bro Froese love hanging with bro so
it's over sonali and his environment is
having an effect on the way sim Graham
is feeling so why don't we click on Ryan
here Ryan still looks pretty peeved and
we can actually see that he's got a
unique interaction type to the way that
sim Graham is feeling as well he can do
a hip bump with Ryan or give a pep talk
or even enthused about his interest
because sim Graham is feeling so
energized so so grumpy man I'm gonna try
the cup time you see up a little bit
earlier how this goes Graham you just so
energized I can see right in your face
like you're not quite buying into it I
love that about our animations you just
read kind of how they're feeling so much
fun and we got a negative outcome just
cuz you're so angry it's tough talking
to you right now you know I've got a
plan now I know that bro is the love to
party so I think we should throw a party
back at our Sims place a little bit
later this evening but before we do that
let's go out into the neighborhood here
and make some new friends maybe we can
invite them over and while our Sims head
over to the bench over here grim wanna
take us on a brief tour of our all-new
neighborhood yeah totally so this is
that first look at those lush vibrant
neighborhoods that we've been talking
about
oh wait who's walking by right here is
that that's a bill Agathe are a jogger
they're having a good time in the arc
and we've got some kids over here having
a good time on the playground
up in the mast of the ship Olivia she's
having a good time that's actually the
Crowsnest ground okay sorry
and somebody a little grumpy today
he's like it's a and Brooks yeah I love
that about the Sims in our neighborhoods
where you just kind of you know do a
little sim watching and you don't even
have to even begin to chat with them you
just see how they're feeling it's pretty
fun to see that variety of how our
gardeners collect in some of the trash
today understand we've got a little
barbecue going on down here
yeah totally a little picnic area it
looks like they've got some hot doggery
go and grab the demo your running has
hot dogs ass oh it's true
now if I were to send my sim down to the
riverbank here I could actually go
fishing and it's gorgeous down here and
if I were to catch something delicious
throw it right on my girl over there
something delicious like a rainbow trout
yummy what that's my favorite joke for
me3 got a lot of booze at e3 with the
rain brother thought I'd try it out you
guys but you know our neighborhoods
they're just beautiful
they're packed with gameplay as well you
know just here's a small example there's
a wild apple tree growing I could send
my sim over there pick a little piece of
fruit off it take it back home plant it
in my garden suddenly my Sims working on
his gardening skill all right now let's
check back in with our sins the hole
it's like Ryan's getting into another
bit of them well I'd like to try and
make some friends I'm not sure Ryan is
gonna best emotion
but right I don't need you making any
head of it let's let's check in with
Graham here now this is actually not a
great opportunity to see not just how
arsons emotions affect their gameplay
but how their personalities do as well
so let's click on who is this guy here
this is a let's see John Brown playing a
little chest at the part of the dice so
when we select him in Kremlin if you
want my pausing it just for a second I
want to talk a bit about these
interactions so we've discussed the
emotion based interactions like the
heartfelt compliment or be now with a
brightness day but we also have a set of
unique interactions that are tied
directly to the personality traits that
we gave to sim Graham so because of who
he is on the inside we get a set of
other unique interactions that are tied
directly to his personality so yeah it
looks like Graham can debate game
strategy because well I can tell he's
playing chess he's got kind of a little
bit of a nerdy have on there so you
might be into a little bit of games I'll
see how this goes for us he's like
bathing with us a bit good time Oh check
that out so I just learned about him
he's actually eat as well and you know
we made Graham the geek earlier this guy
would be perfect to bring to our party I
like your friend so again are some
emotions and our Sims personalities all
tie in to the unique interactions we
have now before anything goes wrong in
this park man I saw you yelling at that
nice lady let's let's get out of here
you gotta work some of that testosterone
out let's down to the job Ryan is in no
place to party so yeah that's actually a
great idea we can go down to the local
gym and have ursins start working out
harder than just the push-ups or sit-ups
that we did and this is actually a great
opportunity to show off another
neighborhood within this world and I you
guys I have to tell you I'm so excited
about these new neighborhoods because
not only can you travel between
neighborhoods but for the first time
ever you can travel between completely
different worlds all while playing the
same save game like in The Sims 3 you
had to start a new game every time you
wanted to go to a new world but in The
Sims 4 they're all tied together you
simply travel between neighborhoods
travel between worlds and all your game
play all of your Sims feelings and
relationships all persist it's so much
fun yeah I really love
all that stuff comes along because just
being able to you know hop over to the
other area find a sin that I like and
then have a relationship bring them back
home I think that's super cool yeah it's
it makes place so much more fun it's all
get us going on these workout machines
I'll do a normal one and you're still
angry so we'll have you do the other
rage through our ups Oh Graham I
actually have an idea come out a bit of
a friendly wager here I bet I can get my
sin to build as athletic study faster
than your staple all right I think we
could do that remember of course some
ground learns the quick learner trail
it's gonna help me with my skill
buildings might be in trouble Sam Ryan
has the act of train and he's also
feeling very I think I've got hearts and
minds working out there do that
Baltimore does I think all the
reinforcements I actually haven't have a
trick up my sleeve by Sam happens to
know the local trainer down here and I
can actually asking for hey check it out
look it's back here on the work unless
re abdominal area yeah it's a bro
straight up and nancy land grab to get
some fan favorites in there let's see if
we can find Jake now the Train oh there
there's Jake Jake Jake the cowboy is the
local trainer I mean only true Cowboys
work out in their cowboy hat cowboy
boots and because he has a higher
athletic skill than Madison I asked him
to mentor myself so he'll come over give
me some tips on this is the magic
immersive
Ryan's channeling his personality trait
did I just raped abilities go faster
he's using his very angry emotion state
to work out harder and stronger and he's
taking advantage of his relationship
Walla Walla festival Graham Coxon
I know you had Jake come over help you
out and look at this look what I noticed
look how many weights I'm lifting
compared to you that's totally cheating
all I said was built there's no faster
cool so again my sim everything about
them helped me build my skill faster
whom I send this their trades and how my
sim is feeling his emotion and his
relationship having been there for me
all it helps me deal with my sins
feeling faster and this is the magic of
our Sims here in the cities for
everything you choose about who they are
and how they are feeling all contributes
to your game you later
and it makes plain with your sense so
much more fun all right bit of a bro
Hagen bro bump card looks like where's
your fellow bro you just feel thank you
feel I'm happy now Ryan's perked up a
little bit you know let's let's get back
home let's let this party let's get
going we can invite Jake over - I'd like
to thank them for helping my same out
here in the gym so we're gonna head back
to our our place and I am a bit worried
that our Sims house is not suitable for
a party yeah you know it works for a
couple of roommates like us but if we're
gonna have cool dudes like Jake come
over we gotta smash this place up a bit
this is actually a cool opportunity
because in The Sims 3 we might place
down some more expensive furniture but
in The Sims 4 this is a great chance for
us to load up the all-new gallery now
you guys know from The Sims 3 that you
can share your content your creations
via The Sims 3 exchange but to do that
you had to leave the game go to the sims
3 website browse for content that you
want download it to your computer
install it through your launcher and
finally start a new game with that
content but in the Sims 4 it's all right
here inside of the game you simply open
up the gallery and bam you have access
to all of the creations all the content
that then Sims community has put
together all right here at your
fingertips houses families individual
Sims can all be directed and integrated
directly into your game with
but it is amazing you guys check out
this one I found earlier I thought this
is perfect for our partner to Mesa
mansion you know it so I'm gonna grab it
just take the furnished version of it
let's pop it right down or a lot we'll
have a party place good to go and just
like that
we've got an all-new house to play with
this is a house a lot that somebody else
has created out there in the world and
all we have to do is simply integrate it
into our game and now it's a part of our
story and we can do whatever we want
with it
yep cool so much fun all right now this
looks like a great house for a party I
think it's just missing a stereo and
we'll be good to go oh yeah good point
now of course I could hop back into the
build catalog just the traditional way
you've always added objects but instead
how about I go back on the gallery
quickly something we've added in Sims 4
is the ability to share and personalize
individual rooms so I saw this Mesa
music lounge and I think this is gonna
be perfect for our party tonight so I'm
just gonna grab it and you'll see
instantly it's been added right to my
cursor downloaded attached I could place
it anywhere on the lot I want so I'm
gonna put it right on the corner there
nice just go in knock the little hole in
the wall so we can get in there and
enjoy it and I think we're good for this
party than I am and it's like right now
in addition to seeing the gallery you're
also getting a glimpse of the all-new
build mode and just like create-a-sim
we've rebuilt it to be hands-on and fun
to play with now you can pick up entire
rooms move them around a lot and all
that content all those furnishings go
right along with it
in addition adjusting your dimensions of
your house and creating unique
architecture is just as easy as drag and
dropping it is so much fun to play with
in the sims 4 the Builder always wins
you can never make a mistake that you
can't easily adjust and fix just with
the click of a button
now we've what I'm really excited about
is some long-standing fan requests like
the ability to change Foundation Heights
on the fly or even adjust the height of
your walls you guys have been asking
this for asking for this from us since
the Sims one I think yeah it's cool all
right it's time to kick this party off
totally so I'm gonna have Graham start a
social
here and you know what we've got a
variety of events for players to choose
from if you and I were some class here
guys come on
maybe we do grinder party tonight but
now let's do the house party let's trash
this place yeah so I'm gonna set my sim
up as the host here perfect and I'm
gonna ask you to hop on the bar for us
mix up some drinks I'd take advantage of
my Sims mix all had you skill and now
let's get some friends over John Brown
one of the cow from the park yeah yeah
let's do that the chess table a Katrina
Caliente
there's Leroy he came over and memory
introduce ourselves
that's rude to kick his ass out because
you were so angry I just I'm sure
apologize let's make sure he comes back
over let's get the land groves owners
Jake Jake oh we gotta get onto and an
Ericsson dapper dude we'll get him I got
a good now let's get the whole dog it's
gonna be a rager yeah man let's do it so
we'll start this party get our party up
it's real already outfits oh you know
what grant I think we've got one more
spot for somebody special right here in
this demo we can do that I think let me
let me open the gallery again we've got
something we can do um I saw a friend
earlier let's get him in here there
y'all do I like this dude you might be
familiar with home so we'll bring him
right up just like that we've added
another sing to our household like this
party yeah in addition to houses and
lots and rooms you can upload and
download sims and families from the
gallery as well it is so much fun to
play with let's go right over here
tending the bar looking on bring our
buddy all you get all him to do some
dancing it looks like some of our guests
have arrived and you know what Graham
I'm feeling
magnets we didn't tell everybody about
our house man oh that's true
you know I'm really not a big fan of
that guy we've kind of invited this guy
to live with us to kind of help
subsidize the rent indeed he always acts
like such a dictator that he's not oh
there's a little dictator no I can't I
can't have him in our party man I'm
gonna get him out of here yeah when
you're living with a dictator you
actually learned some interesting stuff
about him that you might not have
otherwise of known true a little-known
fact about this guy he happens the way
into baking cupcakes huh and he put this
weird cupcake factor
he's been working on his strawberry
fizzy recipe so I don't know it's kind
of a Zen thing he's in such a bad mood
let's have him do a little baking maybe
you'll feel a little better not ruin
this burger how the part is going on
drinks here and always wrong oh shoot
Brian fire arm our bartenders set the
house sorry oh dude so just like that
send one demo a game where everything
was catching on fire don't worry I got
ourselves we're gonna dude you do
something wet himself keys get out oh my
god
this party is falling apart wait a
second
that's hilarious in there cracking that
I miss keeled over and died in a puddle
of pee that's terrible bad i I can't do
this I gotta get out of here
so death fight for you guys that's dying
of hysteria being hysterical well that
was a weird party yeah but a pretty fun
one I think it's still success well this
is probably a good place to wrap things
up The Sims 4 we are so excited about it
launching this September we've got all
new Sims that allow you to tell some
really weird fun stories so we've got
the new creative tools that are so much
more fun to play with and we've got the
gallery that allows you guys to share
your content with the world with just
the click of a button we cannot wait for
you guys to get that your hands on this
game it's launching the first week of
September so thanks for watching
yeah thanks everybody see ya